welcome to Hannity we are following
tonight for big breaking news stories a
lot to get to in the course of this hour
now we begin with the president he just
wrapped up as you know an important
rally in North Carolina Fayetteville
tonight he was in a campaign mode for
the Republican congressional candidate
Dan bishop who is facing an upcoming
special election and in this particular
case he'd see that the US House of
Representatives is important and as we
speak the Democratic majority is not
interested in passing any legislation to
protect our country secure our borders
help bolster our economy create jobs no
they are singularly focused back from
their long vacation on one thing and one
thing only and that's destroying
president Trump and anybody and
everybody who supports him today we got
Jerry Nadler you know the guy from New
York who's suffering from impeachment
arrangment psychosis just directed his
Judiciary Committee to take the first
official step towards impeaching
impeaching the President and beginning
the proceedings of course there are no
high crimes no misdemeanors there is no
justification at all we all know the
Russian witch hunt was a complete utter
failure dud Robert mullahs testimony was
utterly worthless they never got what
they prayed for thought they would get
and wanted and then to top it all off
well articles of impeachment
let me help Nadler out it would be
totally dismissed in the
republican-controlled Senate and by the
way Democrats in those districts that
voted for Trump yeah they're not gonna
like that either
just a prediction basically Democrats
are wasting your money wasting your time
and do nothing to help the American
people nothing
it's beyond pathetic it's an
anti-climatic culmination of three years
of Lies smears conspiracy theories and
frankly just gutter dirty politics and
it possibly all started at the very top
that would be President Obama Joe Biden
breaking tonight just now Judicial Watch
uncovered a new trove of documents
showing how Obama's State Department
officials how they were desperately
trying to undermine then president-elect
Trump in 2016
take a look at these new documents
according to the heavily redacted
materials these officials allegedly
disseminated
intelligence that's illegal and other
classified material that's illegal to
three anti-trump senators all in an
attempt to spread lies propaganda
misinformation Russia collusion innuendo
throughout the highest levels of
government sound familiar
it should after all Hillary Clinton's
phony Russian bought and paid for
dossier the dirty dossier passed around
Obama's DOJ his State Department the US
Senate and remember it was weaponized by
commis FBI both before and after the
2016 election the real question must be
answered we got to get to this point
what did Obama what did Biden what did
Rice what did Brennan clapper Lynch
powers and others know and also when did
they know it now remember we've been
telling you know counterintelligence
operation happens without the direct
knowledge and involvement of the
President of the United States at that
time yeah that would be President Obama